ich habe hier heute in frankfurt etwas
vor das ich seit anfang märz 2020 nicht
gemacht habe ich war noch nie in meinem
leben club ich bin richtig gespannt wir
das ausnutzen und zu habe ich vom gas zu
gehen und sogar ein klub alle berühmten
djs sind durch diesen gang in den club
und bertelsmann unbemerkt von der
öffentlichkeit aber natürlich nicht am
feiern zu gehen und auch nicht um meine
freundinnen zu treffen sondern weil ich
mich frage wann öffnen wieder bars und
clubs und wie wird das dann sein wenn
der schatten vorbei ist und die pandemie
ist wieder zulässt wir bereiten sich
klub besitzer darauf vor
dann merkt man wie sehr man das
eigentlich damit es kommt wieder
ich werde mit einem versprechen und ich
weiß schon aus meinen telefonaten mit
ihnen vor diesen dreh so sie ist vor
kroner war wird es erstmal nicht sein
mein erster von vier stopps ist die m
berry war ihr chef ist dominik geiger
mit ihrer eröffnung hat er sich seinen
großen traum erfüllt der liegt aktuell
auf eis seit november ist die wahl zu
nach dem ersten shutout im frühjahr 2020
schon zum zweiten mal sein lebenswerk
steht auf dem spiel
es ist schon dann natürlich auch
irgendwo der gedankengang dar wofür
macht man das eigentlich anna ist und
ist das überhaupt alles langfristig
überhaupt noch mit perspektive verbunden
also gehen natürlich dann schon auch
gedanken durch den kopf hört man lieber
auf zieht man also rein nüchtern
betrachtet buchhalterisch gesehen
irgendwann die reißleine und dann
kontern geht man halt so diese diese
gratwanderung soll das eines das
emotionale man hängt an seinem
lebenswerk und man hat dafür sehr viel
geopfert und gearbeitet noch sieht es
für dominik finanziell gut aus er hofft
dass seine bar in shutter und überlebt
doch auch wenn das klappt ist die krise
für ihn längst nicht vorbei hast du
fängst danach eigentlich wieder bei null
du musst deine stammgäste wie du dir
lange zeit erarbeitet hast natürlich
dann auch wieder abholen
wir arbeiten da insofern gegen das wir
wenn wir wieder aufmachen werden kleine
speisen konzept mit dazu nehmen werden
und tatsächlich eine neue karte haben
werden und ein paar veränderungen machen
werden um den leuten auch einen gewissen
anreiz zu bieten zu sagen hey
die sind wieder am start las man
hingehen die haben neue drinks zusammen
machen wir uns auf den weg zu zwei
kollegen von dominik er ist gut vernetzt
und ich will auch noch von anderen
besitzern wissen was planen sie für die
wiedereröffnung werden sie die krise
überhaupt überleben wird man hier in
frankfurt und anderen städten weiterhin
gut von einer zur nächsten beziehen
können oder droht ein bar und club
sterben in der branche sind die sorgen
groß
laut einer umfrage des verband dehoga
bangen 64 prozent der gastronomen und
hoteliers aktuell um ihre existenz rund
25 prozent überlegen sogar ob sie
aufgeben und ihren betrieb schließen
darüber spreche ich vor meinem dreh in
frankfurt mit der hauptgeschäftsführerin
des verbands die situation ist
dramatisch
wenn ich hier an betrieben vorbeilaufen
die also sehr gefährdet sind und wo die
fenster steigen zugeklebt sind also in
innenstädten wird es denke ich besonders
katastrophal sein dort fallen die auch
immer hohe pachten an die in echt großer
kostenblock sind für die betriebe hier
nennt statt nein da wird sich denke ich
einiges verändern bis zu unserem ersten
stock sind es nur ein paar hundert meter
das sullivan normalerweise tummeln sich
hier auf zwei etagen nach feierabend
managerinnen und banker später kommt
touristin und party publikum dazu an
guten abenden hat das allen bis zu 600
gäste das erzählt mir christian weber
erst hier betriebsleiter mit seinem
überleben ja wir haben vor gut
gewirtschaftet und deshalb überstehen
wir lassen es ist zwar hart und es ist
eng und wir müssen hin und herschieben
geld technisch aber wir werden es
erleben was macht das so hart die
laufenden kosten wahrscheinlich was ist
das was man es war also eigentlich ist
es das schlimme daran ist irgendwie alle
zu vertrösten ja also das jetzt den
vermieter ist oder lieferanten sind aber
was die zu vertrösten es kommt geld
sobald wir halt staatliche hilfe
bekommen was aber halt nicht passiert er
wartet noch auf seinen kasten auf alles
wir haben kleine abschlag bekommen aber
das denkt natürlich in keinster weise
irgendwelche kosten um die geschlossenen
bars und andere unternehmen zu
unterstützen hat die bundesregierung
verschiedene hilfsprogramme an den start
gebracht die november und dezember
hilfen oder überbrückungshilfen zuletzt
die überbrückungshilfe drei davon sollen
bis juni 2021 fixe kosten wie mieten
oder versicherungen bezahlt werden
können auch wenn der umsatz fehlt
dominik christian und viele andere
gastronomen sind auf das geld angewiesen
um überhaupt pläne für die zeit nach
ende des schattens schmieden zu können
doch bei vielen unternehmen kommen die
november und dezember hilfen nur sehr
schleppend an
laut einer umfrage der dehoga haben fast
37 prozent der betriebe die beantragte
november hilfe noch nicht vollständig
bekommt und rund 77 prozent warten noch
auf die vollständige auszahlung der
dezember hilfen
die gründe dafür sind laut
wirtschaftsministerium von bund und
ländern vor allem probleme mit dem
system über das die hilfen beantragt
werden
manche bundesländer nennen außerdem als
grund für die lange wartezeit eine
außergewöhnliche antragsflut
also was erwartet uns dann wenn ihr die
türen endlich wieder aufmachen könnte
würde man sagen ist alle sind froh wenn
sie wieder dürfen ja es wird
es wird mit sicherheit mit richtig
großen auflagen aufzumachen sein
vielleicht auch erst nach ostern denkmal
es wird sperrzeiten mit sicherheit geben
wir können nicht wie wir vor einem jahr
noch bislang morgens um vier feiern es
wird nicht funktionieren
aber alle werden froh sein und es wird
für alle was dabei sein um endlich
wieder gute soziale kontakte zu knüpfen
und ein zu trinken das heißt du nimmst
du das alles nehmen was die politik
erlaubt damit es endlich weitergehen
kann
alles also wenn ich schwer zeiten für
claassen vorher ein schnelltest machen
ja es muss ja weitergehen wir arbeiten
tatsächlich einmal neuen küchenkonzept
wir arbeiten
wir werden die öffnungszeiten wirklich
ändern werden tagsüber aufmachen um
einfach auf dieses diesen ausfall wieder
reinzuholen und dann wird wird sich
zeigen was wir dürfen das das wird
abstandsregeln geben es wird ein rus
regeln geben schnelltests was auch immer
wir werden das maximum rausholen müssen
müssen neue öffnungszeiten neue
cocktails neue speisen die bars wollen
sich ein stück neu erfinden um gäste
anzulocken corona konformen auflagen
gerecht zu werden und wieder geld zu
verdienen
wann das so weit ist weiß niemand genau
der einzelhandel soll wieder öffnen
können wenn die sieben tage incidents in
einem bundesland oder einer region unter
50 ist
bleibt das so sollen cafés oder
restaurants zumindest ihre terrassen
wieder öffnen dürfen bars oder clubs
sind laut neuestem beschluss wohl als
letzte dran
ja da ist noch viel lernstoff vor uns
und die politik muss die weichen dafür
stellen weil wir müssen ja irgendwie
umgehen
mit diesem corona virus das wird ja
morgen oder in zwei drei monaten nicht
verschwunden sein dominik und ich haben
noch eine zweite verabredung auf der
berger straße
sie ist in frankfurt ein beliebtes aus
gezielt zur zeit gibt es not to go
verkauf der restaurants cafés oder bars
wie der von anthony konstantes ich mache
gerade sowieso 17 uhr auf und donnerstag
freitag samstag und 17 uhr und warte
einfach mal dass die leute vorbeikommen
also das heißt ein bisschen was geht
noch bei dir oder das ist der mehr
beschäftigung szenerie alles alles
anders also man kann nicht unbedingt
sagen da geht viel oder da geht wenig
das ist einfach mal okay ich gehe mal
dahin habe ich meine routine weiter
genauso wie vorher und auch mal endlich
bisschen weg von der couch wir haben die
komplette getränkekarte ein angebot an
cocktails to go und die leute können das
dann eben online aussuchen was sie
wollen und dann bewarb oder e-mail oder
einen kurzen anruf bestellen was sie
wollen und wann hast du denn für heute
bestellungen kommt heute nach etwas ab
es sollte gar nicht ich bleibe trotzdem
hier von 5 bis 9
ja manchmal kommen auch alle stammkunden
vorbei mal hallo zu sagen sie mal fragen
hey wie gehts oder soja und wie gesagt
das ist schon mal auch gut genug sehr
auf das man nicht dem vergessen in
vergessenheit geht bislang sehr wichtig
anthony erzählt uns für ihn fühle sich
das shutter und an wie ein
langstreckenlauf bei dem ihm aber vorher
niemand gesagt habe wie lange er laufen
müssen und wann es auf dem weg wasser
gebe wasser sind in dem fall die hilfen
die die regierung zugesagt hat denn auch
er wartet noch auf einen teil des geldes
der ihm bewilligt wurde
große hoffnungen setzt er in die
erlaubnis die terrasse öffnen zu dürfen
und ich hoffe dass wir einfach genau da
weitermachen wo wir aufgehört haben
ich sags mal so mit den ersten lockdown
im märz um appel und dann dürften wir
wieder aufmachen
ich konnte im laden nur zwei gäste haben
nein natürlich nicht
falls es doch ab mitte april oder ende
april wie auch immer weiß man eben nicht
ja losgehen könnte dann ist dann wieder
ein bisschen wärmer also tatsächlich
kleinen laden oder große laden wenn man
dann eben eine terrasse hat kann man
dann eben
ein bisschen haben wir mehr chancen zu
überleben und was zu machen alles andere
leben die gar nichts haben
ich verabschiede mich von antony und
dominik denn ich will noch wissen wie es
einem club in frankfurt geht die hatten
ja den ganzen sommer zu weit ist ein
jahr ohne partys herum wie wird es
dieses jahr sein eine letzte verabredung
habe ich heute noch und zwar im gibson
das ist ein großer klub auf der zeil in
frankfurt wir stehen gerade am
hintereingang denn ich bin hier mit
einem der besitzer verabredet und mit
ihm darüber zu sprechen was der club
schon getan hat um endlich wieder gäste
empfangen zu dürfen denn der schotter
und einmal vorbei ist
er hat mir am telefon schon verraten
dass sie sogar schon umgebaut haben und
er meinte ich sage ich einfach mal
anrufen und dann wird er runter kommen
also mal gucken ob ich ihnen jetzt auch
erreichen
ja wir sind da wir stehen wir stehen
weil er bei der achter ist das richtig
bei der hessen-wahl hey wie sehr freut
nicht nur dass es klappt ich war noch
nie im leben club ich bin richtig
gespannt wer das was außen also etwas
ganz anderes zeug nochmal walk of fame
jason durch diesmal eingang in den club
konnte unbemerkt von der öffentlichkeit
ein walk of fame gefühl spüre ich nicht
so richtig kein wo man da bass keine
feiernden menschen stattdessen eine
lehre garderobe eine staubige bar und
eine mit sofas folge stellte tanzfläche
das ist der heilige gibt's klub wie
sieht es ja sonst aus normaler ist
natürlich von der menschen ja eng an eng
war
flackerndes licht laute musik und
fröhliche gesichter viel lachen tanzen
singen wir sind sehr sehr also bei merck
das erste mal wirklich mal wieder hier
ist mal wieder richtig laute musik hört
wir haben neulich den streaming gemacht
hinten im backstage um unsere gäste ein
bisschen bei laune zu halten und das hat
sich so toll angefühlt wie der laute
musik zu hören also da merkt man wie
sehr man das eigentlich vermisst es
kommt wieder
ja wann kommt wieder gute frage also ich
glaube dass wir dieses jahr noch öffnen
da glaube ich fest daran
wir planen mit september
natürlich mit reduzierter kapazität
hygieneregeln nachverfolgung alles was
dazugehört wahrscheinlich mit testen
testen impfung als kombination und ich
hoffe mal dass wir nächstes jahr auch
wieder die tanzflächen erben können ok
also das heißt dieses jahr ab september
sagst du kann er wieder tanzen
man kann ganz nah am tisch also man
sieht dass hier so ein bisschen wir
haben das ist jetzt natürlich alles noch
nicht an seinem finalen platz aber wir
haben abtrennungen geschafft und
zwischen den einzelnen tisch bereichen
das heißt wir haben reservierte plätze
überall im ganzen club
wir haben also keine offene tanzfläche
keine offene bewegung und da kann man
sich eben darin seinen platz buchen und
am platz pflanzen okay natürlich würden
mieten mit meinen freundinnen und
freunden kann ich mir nun platz bieten
sag ich komme von iks also weiß ich
nicht von 11 bis 14 uhr und dann kann
ich hier getränke bestellen können auch
getränke bestellen alles natürlich
kontaktlos das heißt mit quark wie man
es gelernt hat jetzt die letzten monate
wir wissen genau wer wo wie zusammen
sitzt deswegen auch diese
nachverfolgbarkeit wenn ich dann auf
toilette gehen muss schnee maske
aufsetzen aber ich gehe jetzt nicht mehr
selbst an die bauern hohmann getränk das
wird mir alles gebracht der klub hat
sein konzept schon mit dem
gesundheitsamt besprochen aber tanzen am
tisch ich weiß ja nicht ob das das party
gefühl ersetzen kann dass ich vermisse
nichts wird spontan möglich sein weil
eben raus aus dem klub und wieder rein
oder quatschen mit den menschen am
nebentisch
andererseits ist der wunsch bei vielen
endlich mal wieder feiern zu gehen
natürlich groß und dass gibson wäre auch
über 400 statt vorher 1000 gäste froh
andere einfach dass sie den shutdown
überstanden haben
mein fazit die jungs haben richtig bock
dass es wieder losgeht und sie haben
pläne
wie das dann sein wird es wird konzepte
geben die es möglich machen deshalb
weder mit freunden und freundinnen in
eine bar gehen können oder sogar tanzen
können
und auch wenn das heißt dass wir dann an
dem tisch tanzen müssen
es wird möglichkeiten leben versteht
mich nicht falsch dass es aktuell nicht
so ist es absolut richtig
aber wenn es soweit ist wenn klar ist
man die läden wieder öffnen
dann wird es irgendwie weitergehen
[Musik]
wie geht es euch wie sehr vermisst ihr
das feiern die bars und die klubs
erzählt uns da von unten in den
kommentaren
und wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat
dann lasst doch bleibt außerdem empfehle
ich euch diese beiden videos hier
wenn ihr die zeit bis zum ende des lok
downs mit youtube videos schauen
verbringen wollte